What up, Ilana?
So I-- I bit into a jawbreaker,
and my veneer fell out,
and now I am
a literal monster.
I didn't know you
had a veneer,
and I'm in that mouth
on a regular basis.
Well, I broke it
on a dog bone,
so I don't tell
a lot of people,
to be honest.
You know, since
we're bein' honest,
I want to share with you that
I have prosthetic balls.
What?
I'm just kiddin'!
So, can you fix it?
Yeah, I'm not doin'
anything right now.
(mumbling)
Chill. I'm on
the phone, man.
So the earliest I could
see you is 4:30.
Thank you
so much, dude.
All right,
so where were we?
Oh, yeah.
Yeesh! These all
gotta come out.
What?
I'm just kiddin'.
I'm a real jokester
today-- I had that one,
and the one earlier
about prosthetic balls.
I'm crushin' it,
two for two all day.